[Music]
some of the hardest hit cities in this
pandemic are getting help from traveling
healthcare workers from across the
country
in march atlanta nurse practitioner
decoya billy received an emergency
request
for nurses to report to new york city
and didn't hesitate for a moment
now four months later she's serving in a
hospital outside san antonio texas
maria villarreal shows us how the long
stretches away
are affecting her family back home
as the need for health care workers on
the front lines of the covet 19 pandemic
increases traveling nurses bring relief
to hospitals
across the country nurse practitioner
decoya billy is one of those people
back in march she packed her bags and
left atlanta for what was then the
center of the epicenter
new york city i understand that
most people couldn't do this but it's my
passion
and each story each experience with
patients
it just reaffirms that this is what i
was called to do
a calling that means leaving behind her
husband marcus and their four children
including their seven month old twins
pumping breast milk during the work days
and shipping at home on the weekends how
are you doing that wonder woman
um you know i i don't think about it i
know it's something i have to do
how do you explain what mommy's doing
right now i get asked all the time mom
when you're coming back
when i finish facetiming at the end of
the night it's always this is my
four-year-old mom i hope you come back
to my house
i said yeah i'm gonna come as soon as
mom is finished helping to save lives
after nearly two months of working
12-hour shifts in new york city
and a month back in atlanta billy was
called to a hospital in texas to help
fight the overwhelmed state
was there a point where you could have
said no i don't want to do this
yes there at any point i could have
backed out did you ever think about that
it was new york now it's texas that
needs us
billy says she's helping the people of
texas by bringing her knowledge from new
york
and by working in covid units away from
home she's protecting her own family
with the support of her husband marcus
why don't you tell us it's lifelike i
mean you've got four kids with you
i mean this is this is crazy um you know
just getting them up in the morning
you know getting them fed arranging bath
times
um arranging travel when we need to
leave the house
definitely been an adjustment but we've
been grateful to have a lot of help
along the way and whether it's atlanta
or another city that needs help next
time
billy will be ready i'm not at all
deserving of
the blessings that i have but and i know
that because of it i'm
charged to give back i hate to be such a
quick baby but
it means that much to me for cbs this
morning
midday dallas texas
wow what a remarkable story i think we
both looked at each other when we're
saying calling and then you hear and she
has four children yes
i don't know who's a bigger hero decoy
or marcus because he's doing all that
work at home
she's going to texas and new york
12-hour shifts
thank you to both of them for everything
that they're doing for your service